[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tract en 1919 il ya cent ans
une éclipse solaire confirme que
l'univers n'est plus que l'on croyait
que les étoiles et des galaxies
obéissent bel et bien aux idées
surprenantes un certain albert einstein
[Musique]
l'histoire commence au tournant du
siècle le jeune einstein échafaude
pendant des années sa vision d'univers
la théorie de la relativité générale
d'abord avec l'idée que le temps et
l'espace sont intimement liés et forme
un tout l'espace temps en présence d'une
masse comme une étoile cet espace-temps
se défend tout ce qui circule à
proximité que ce soit une planète où un
rayon de lumière doit suivre des courbes
de l'espace-temps est dévié de sa
trajectoire
la gravité serait donc le résultat des
déformations et non une force
mystérieuse
c'est une idée révolutionnaire mais en
1915 c'est surtout une idée allemande et
l'a vérifié est loin d'être une priorité
il faut attendre la fin de la guerre
pour que les astres s'alignent et ce
littéralement on prévoit en mai 1919 une
éclipse solaire totale quand la lune
bloquera le soleil on pourra apercevoir
les étoiles tout autour vu de la terre
on connaît bien la position des étoiles
les unes par rapport aux autres si
einstein a raison avec le soleil dans
les parages l'espace temps devrait se
déformer un peu et affecter le parcours
de leurs lumières
résultat on aura l'impression que
certaines étoiles se sont déplacés la
déviation réel est un film
la mesure est est tout un défi pour
l'époque
l'astronome britannique arthur eddington
décide de relever
il met le cap sur une petite île
d'afrique de l'ouest
mais le jour j le ciel est couvert de
nuages et les rares photos des clips ce
sont à peine utilisable heureusement il
avait envoyé une deuxième équipe au
brésil
et en recoupant les observations avec
celles d'afrique
on mesure une déviation qui correspond
parfaitement à ce que la relativité
générale prévoit toujours l'homme le nom
d'einstein devient synonyme de génie et
la relativité générale un des fondements
de la physique
aujourd'hui cet effet de lentille
gravitationnelle permet de révéler ce
qui se cache derrière des galaxies
lointaines
un véritable feu d'artifice en l'honneur
du plus célèbre des physiciens
[Musique]